hey everyone welcome to the David Pacman
show I'm producer Pat Ford filling in
for David today as he is traveling in
California we're gonna have guest hosts
for the remainder of the week so some
pretty big news on the Donald Trump
indictment front happened over the
weekends Donald Trump was interviewed by
Brett Bear on Fox News and he couldn't
get through the 20-minute or so exchange
without incriminating himself multiple
times admitting to doing the very things
that he's been accused of in this
Federal indictment Donald Trump has been
doing media interviews he's been doing
these rallies wherein he talks about the
criminal charges and basically admits to
the fact that he had these classified
documents in his possession and
obstructed Justice thereafter this is of
course a terrible idea for any criminal
defendant any Council defense lawyers
would advise you not to speak about the
case but because Donald Trump is running
for president and he needs to at all
times appear like he's a fighter he
believes he's smarter than everyone else
he is deciding to just do it anyway to
talk about the case and what he's been
doing really is giving himself more and
more rope to hang himself with and
that's because generally speaking the
prosecution can use such statements that
you make in the media
to establish your guilt or to try to
undermine your defense arguments and
legally it can get more complicated of
course because you get into a
conversation about what is and what
isn't admissible in court what does and
what doesn't qualify is hearsay but
there's a strong case that these media
interviews like the one we're about to
look at by Trump will end up being used
as exhibits in his upcoming trial so the
bottom line is this is why you stay
silent I think it was Ron philipkowski
on Twitter who said that if the 500 best
lawyers in the entire world told Donald
Trump to stay silent on this matter he
would disregard them thinking that he
was smarter than all of them and then
Maga would use that as justification to
vote for him because they would think
that that's some sort of qualification
for being president even though that
would actually make him the worst
possible choice to be president zeroing
in on the most damaging things that
Donald Trump said during this interview
Trump admits uh to taking the documents
down to Mar-A-Lago with him and that he
had the these boxes of documents in his
possession that they were interspersed
with his personal possessions and this
is all going to the charge of willful
retention of National Defense
information he's admitting to the whole
thing here let's take a look at the clip
why did you have this very sensitive
National Security defense documents like
the war plans for a strike on Iran so
like every other president I take things
out and in my case I took it out pretty
much in a hurry but people packed it up
and we we left and I had clothing in
there I had all sorts of personal items
and there much much stuff I have every
right to have those boxes this is purely
a presidential records act this is not a
criminal thing in fact the New York
Times have all had a story just the
other day that the only way Nara could
ever get this stuff this back would be
please please please could we have it
back because they had
and then they said they went to doj to
subpoena you to get which they've never
done before right and you know why not
just hand them over them because I had
boxes I want to go through the boxes and
get all my personal things out I don't
want to hand that over to Nara yet and I
was very busy as you've sort of seen
yeah but according to your diamonds you
then tell this Aid to move to other
locations after telling your lawyers to
say you'd fully complied with the
subpoena when you hadn't but before I
send boxes over I have to take all of my
things out these boxes were interspersed
with all sorts of things uh golf shirts
clothing pants shoes there were many
things I would say much much more not
that I know of but not that I know of so
it's hard not to laugh when Trump is
talking about his golf shirts and his
shoes that he had to take out before
sending the boxes back from Nara but I
think that the key takeaway from the
entire statement here is that he does
admit to taking the documents he admits
that he was in contact with Nera about
sending them back and his defense was
essentially that he was too busy he
didn't have time to get around to it
even though he was subpoenaed in this
case and once you receive a subpoena
you're supposed to realize oh this is
actually serious if the fact that you
were in contact with authorities before
the subpoena wasn't enough of a message
to take this thing seriously The
subpoena should have done it for you but
he decided to continue to ignore it and
to have his lawyers lie to the
authorities about what exactly he had in
his possession remember that key in this
case is the charge of willful retention
of National Defense information that's
what 31 of the 37 counts hinge on and
he's saying yeah I did it it wouldn't
matter if his golf shirts were also in
there or if they weren't in there or if
he had time to get around to it or if he
didn't have time to get around to it
he seems to be guilty of these crimes
now let's move on to the audio tape this
is something that prosecutors have in
their possession tape of Donald Trump
while he's showing a guest of his who
presumably doesn't have a security
clearance classified material and he
admits that he could have Declassified
it while he was president but he didn't
and now he doesn't have the authority to
do so anymore so therefore it is still
classified Trump's arguments surrounding
his right to have these documents depend
on him saying that he could have
Declassified whatever he wanted to as
president telepathically even right well
this isn't true because we've heard from
experts about this there's this process
that you have to go through to
declassify information particularly when
it comes to things like nuclear secrets
and other top level confidential
information that the government has but
even if it was true this tape that
prosecutors have completely undermines
the argument right because we know for
sure that Donald Trump didn't even
attempt to declassify the documents by
declaration telepathically or otherwise
and now he can't because he's no longer
president he admits to this so this is
among the strongest pieces of evidence
that the prosecution has it's really
what could end up doing him in and Trump
is doing himself no favors by talking
about this very specific piece of uh
information of evidence that the
prosecution has and he provides just the
absolute worst defense that anyone could
possibly come up with falling right into
the Trap of talking about it because
Brett Bear happened to bring it up
according to the indictment you were
here at Bedminster on July 21 2021 after
you're no longer president and you were
recorded saying that you had a document
detailing a planned attack on another
country that was prepared by the U.S
military for you when you were president
the Iran attack plan you remember that
I had lots of paper I had copies of
newspaper articles I had copies of
magazines I said specifically a quote
you're quoted on the recording saying
the document was secret adding that you
could have Declassified it while you
were president but quote now I can't you
know this is still secret highly
confidential and the indictment sites
the recording and the testimony from
people in the room saying you showed it
to people there that day so you say on
this on tape this is just the opposite
that you can't declassify so why have it
what I said when I said that I couldn't
be classified now that's because I
wasn't president I I never made any
bones about that when I'm not president
I can't eat less if that's what you said
you did you said that classified I said
no no I said I couldn't have that
possible document Brad there was no
document that was a massive amount of
papers and everything else talking about
Iran and other things and it may have
been held up or may not but that was not
a document I didn't have a document per
se there was nothing to declassify these
were newspaper stories magazine stories
and articles I'm just saying what the
indictment said so number one Donald
Trump does not deny that the recording
exists or that the conversation happened
which is interesting because I've been
hearing in many right-wing circles on
right-wing programs that the audio tape
was clearly artificial intelligence they
can't come up with any sort of
reasonable excuse for why Trump would be
saying this so they're saying okay it
must have been a deep fake you can do a
lot with AI these days but Donald Trump
himself is not using that excuse right
he's not even disputing the fact that
the conversation took place he's
disputing what the conversation was
about but he's not disputing that it
happened or that that was him in that
conversation so we can put to bed now
this weak excuse that the right has come
up with that that must have been a i and
not actually Trump on the recording
furthermore Trump says that these
weren't documents that he was showing
his guests but instead they were
newspaper clippings and articles and I
don't know how Brett Baer didn't pick up
on this in real time but this is a
totally nonsensical statement right how
could newspaper clippings and articles
be considered government classified
documents by their very definition
newspaper clippings and articles are
meant for public consumption whereas
government secrets are kept as these
private documents and Donald Trump says
on the tape it's classified I'm not
supposed to be showing you this so
Donald Trump really just digging himself
his own grave and he's had plenty of
time to come up with a proper defense
when it comes to the audio tape
specifically that's the most damaging
piece of evidence seemingly against him
and this is all he can do just kind of
stumble around and again all this stuff
can be used against him in court
presumably so obviously this is a unique
case I don't think he's going to take a
plea deal or anything like this because
he has to show that he's a true fighter
but with all this stuff and with all the
damaging things that he said to the
media all the times that he's implicated
himself that would be the best course of
action for him he's not going to go
through with that most likely he's going
to go to trial and I'm sure he's banking
on the fact that he has this right-wing
judge that he appointed presiding over
the case and the possibility that
because the trial is being held in South
Florida there'll be enough trumpists on
the jury to get him the not guilty
verdict or maybe give him a hung jury I
think that's what he's trying to do here
and I understand how he feels as if he
has to talk about the case because of
the politics of it because he's running
for president again and he has to look
like a fighter but it's just not good
strategically from a criminal
prosecution standpoint if you're trying
to stay out of prison and one more clip
I wanted to show you from this Brett
Bear interview
Brett Bear talked about how Trump has to
bring new voters into his camp in order
to defeat Biden in 2024 and so Brett
Baier asked the question if you're
speaking one-on-one to an independent
voter how are you going to convince them
to vote for you in 2024 if they didn't
vote for you in 2020 and without missing
a step Donald Trump goes right into
conspiracy theories about the 2020
election the question wasn't even about
the 2020 election specifically and
whether Trump won or lost but Trump has
to jump right in and say that he
actually won the election even though
this was not being disputed at the time
Brett Baer so let's take a look at this
and so to the female independent voter
in the suburbs who struggled with family
financing because of inflation she's now
against Biden disapproves Biden but
wasn't with you in 2020 and so far is a
hard no for you in 2024 but what do you
say what do you say to that female
independent Suburban voter who feels
that way to win her back first of all I
won in 2020 by a lot okay let's get that
straight I won in 2020. you know and if
you look at all of the tapes if you look
at everything that you want to look at
you take a look at truth to vote where
they have people stuffing the ballot
boxes on tapes or Mr President well wait
a minute let's go to recent FBI Twitter
let's go to recent the 51 agents all
corrupt stuff bro everybody
but that's cheating on them you lost the
2020 election uh Brad you take a look at
all of the stuff ballots you take a look
at all of the things including things
like the 51 intelligence ages there were
recounts in all of the Swing states
there was not significant ones we're
trying to get recounts real recounts
numbers widespread corruption there was
not a sense of that there were lawsuits
more than 50 of them by your lawyers
some in front of judges judges that you
appointed look at Wisconsin they came
out with Wisconsin
Wisconsin is practically admitted it was
rigged other states are doing the same
right now and it's continuing
every potential case of voter fraud in
six Battleground States and they found
fewer than 475 cases you know why
because they didn't look at the right
thing okay are you going they were
counting they were counting about
balance not the authenticity of the
ballot the ballots were fake ballots you
had this was a very rigorous are you
going to go this is how you're going to
tell that independent Suburban woman
voter to vote off to winning an election
and I think we're winning very well uh I
got a poll just recently I have it here
on no no I know okay so it's not even
worth going through Donald Trump's
claims there one by one we've done that
ad nauseum over the years and Brett
Baird does a decent job at fact checking
him in real time but I thought that bear
especially did well at the end there by
emphasizing the fact that his question
was about how do you win over an
undecided female independent voter who
didn't vote for you in 2020 and your
response has been to complain about
voter fraud even though the public is
tired of hearing about this issue it's
not a winning issue for you it's not a
voting issue for people Independence
especially it's not policy you're not
being convincing when you talk about
this it's uninspiring and then Trump
tries to course correct but instead of
doing it in the standard way and of
talking about you know the normal policy
issues the economy the Border guns even
culture War stuff if you want to get
into it instead he diverts into talking
about how he's winning in all the polls
so people should vote for him because
he's winning like how does this add up
how does this follow logically so
Trump's appeal to the independent voter
who didn't vote for him in 2020 is
number one the election was rigged in
2020 and it was unfairly stolen for me
therefore I deserve another term
and number two I'm winning in the polls
already so you should vote for me
because I'm winning so I gotta say this
guy doesn't look like his normal self he
seems a little bit rattled I'm sure he's
worried about the possibility of serving
time in prison I'm sure he's worried
about the possibility of not winning an
election again because it devastated him
so much the last time that happened
maybe I'm looking too much into the body
language maybe I'm looking too much into
the facial expressions but to me this
seems like a very concerned man who
doesn't have the Poise and the
confidence that he normally does that's
Donald Trump for you right now not
feeling his best I gotta say and not
getting the best end end of this
exchange with Brett Bear all right we're
going to go to a break now we'll be back
with much more of the David Pacman show
on the other side
whether you're a carpenter painter or
just want to be prepared for emergencies
if you need a gas mask or respirator go
to our sponsor parcel safety as many of
you know I'm into emergency preparedness
not crazy prepping but I want to have
some food stored some supplies I've
talked about water and multiple
respirators are part of that because
it's just a staple of being prepared
respirator sales have been way up in
recent years natural disasters wildfires
polluted air chemical plant accidents
unrest of different kinds militarized
police all sorts of different reasons
you never know when a respirator or a
gas mask from parcel safety might come
in handy and it could be when you least
expect it parcel safety respirators are
also perfect for professionals
contractors painters people doing DIY
projects at home all of parcel safety's
respirators come with a one-year
manufacturer's warranty every respirator
or gas mask comes with a filter
competitive prices large discounts for
organizations and outstanding customer
service to be totally honest I've said
before I'm using these for changing baby
diapers people think I'm kidding and
then they come visit me and I really am
not it it actually is very useful to
other parents out there I do recommend
it go to davidpackman.com safety use the
code Pacman for 25 off your first order
the link is down below